طبول الحرب التي دقت لم تصمت بعد لكن
المسومه على اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بدات
بالفعل فرئيس اكبر شركه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا اكد ان اعاده بناء اوكرانيا
ضروريه ليس من باب الرحمه ولكن من منطلق
مصلحه تجاريه عمليه حيث اقر ان اصلاح
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه المحطمه في البلاد
سيكلف المليارات لكن انفاقه تلك الاموال
سيساعد اوروبا على اكمال تحولها بعيدا عن
الطاقه الروسيه وفق تعبيرا فرغم الحرب
تواصل روسيا استخدام شبكه خطوط الانابيب
الضخمه في اوكرانيا لارسال الغاز الى
زبائنها المتضائلين بينهم سلوفاكيا
تهدف الى استبدال الغاز الذي يتدفق حاليا
من روسيا للاتحاد الاوروبي عبر اوكرانيا
بالغاز الاوكراني لكنه اوكرانيا التي تروج
حاليا لنفسها كبديل لروسيا في تصدير
الطاقه الى اوروبا على يقين هي بان
الاستبدال الكامل للصادرات موسكو من الغاز
غير ممكن فخططها تتمثل بامدادات كافيه لت
لبيه مؤقته لاحتياجات اوروبا اثناء
انتقالها الى الطاقه الخضراء علما بان
اوكرانيا تمتلك ثاني او ثالث اكبر
احتياطيات وموارد للغاز الطبيعي في اوروبا
والمقدره باكثر من تريليون متر مكعب من
الغاز الطبيعي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات